There's a 200 year old Russian census
that fundamentally
challenges what we've been
told about one of the world's most
intractable ethnic conflicts.
When historians finally gained access to
this forgotten document
after the Soviet Union
fell, it revealed
something extraordinary.
100.000 people just fled their ancestral
homeland in 2023, because
both Armenia and Azerbaijan
had been weaponizing the same historical
myths for generations.
And here's why this matters to you.
This exact playbook, manipulating history
to justify ethnic
cleansing, is being deployed
in conflicts worldwide right now.
Once you understand how it works, you'll
recognize it everywhere.
In fact, it is so powerful that even
after all the death and
destruction, both countries
are still struggling to
sign a binding peace agreement.
Armenia returned four strategic villages
to Azerbaijan in May
2024, and by August 2025,
both leaders were at the White House
promising to jointly
nominate Donald Trump for a Nobel
Peace Prize.
But they still only initialized a
memorandum, not a final treaty.
Let me show you how fabricated history
became deadly reality, and
why even now, after 100.000
people lost their homes, the mythology is
so powerful that
lasting peace remains elusive.
For three decades, Armenia and Azerbaijan
had told the
international community fundamentally
incompatible stories
about the same territory.
The Armenian narrative
goes something like this.
Nagona Karabakh has always
been Armenian land for millennia.
Stalin gave it to Azerbaijan in 1921 as
part of the violent rule.
The 1988 movement was peaceful
self-determination
that was met with pogroms.
The Azerbaijani narrative says Karabakh
has always been
Azerbaijani territory, Armenians
are recent colonizers brought by Russia.
The conflict is about territorial
aggression, not self-determination.
Here's what's fascinating.
Both sides invoke ancient history, both
claim to be indigenous,
and both present themselves
as victims.
So who's telling the truth?
The answer is more complex and more
disturbing than either
side wants you to know.
In the 1990s,
something remarkable happened.
The Soviet archives opened, and scholars
could finally access
primary documents that had
been sealed away for 70 years.
UCLA historian George Bournouttian made a
discovery that would
shake the foundations
of Azerbaijan's historical narrative.
Working in Moscow's central library, he
found to complete 1823
Russian imperial census
of Karabakh province.
Why does this 1823 matter?
Because it is five years before the
Treaty of Turkmenchay",
when Russia gained Eastern
Armenia from Persia.
Azerbaijan has always claimed that
Armenians only came to
Karabakh after 1828, brought
by Russian colonizers.
But this census, conducted village by
village, family by
family, tells a different story.
The data is unambiguous.
In the highland districts that would
become Nagorno-Karabakh, the
population was 95% Armenian.
These weren't recent arrivals.
Church records, cemetery inscriptions,
and tax documents from
the 1720s all corroborate
multi-generational Armenian presence.
Now Azerbaijan historians raise a
legitimate methodological question.
The census was conducted in winter,
potentially missing nomadic Turkic
populations who used
summer pastures.
But here's the crucial point.
Even accounting for seasonal migration,
the demographic evidence is overwhelming.
The Armenian majority in highland
Karabakh predates any
Russian involvement.
So why does Azerbaijan insist Armenians
were brought by Russia?
Because admitting indigenous Armenian
presence undermines their
entire legal argument for
sovereignty.
If Armenians were always there, the
self-determination
claim gains legitimacy.
Conversely, why do Armenians sometimes
overstate their historical
presence in all of Karabakh,
not just the highlands?
Because maximalist historical claims
justify holding
territories beyond Nagorno-Karabakh
proper.
Territories from which 700,000
Azerbaijanis were expelled.
To understand how historical truth gets
systematically buried, meet
Zia Bunyadov, Soviet war hero,
vice-chairman of Azerbaijan's Academy of
Sciences, and perhaps the most
influential historical
forger of the 20th century.
Bunyadov faced a
complex problem in the 1960s.
How do you build a Muslim national
identity while claiming Christian
monuments that obviously
predate Islam's arrival?
His solution was audacious.
Those Armenian churches?
They were not Armenian.
They were built by Caucasian Albanians,
an extinct Christian
people that modern Azerbaijanis
supposedly descended from.
When international scholars gained access
to archives after 1981,
they discovered something
shocking.
British scholar Thomas De Waal documents
in Black Garden that
Bunyadov seminal 1960 and
1965 articles were direct
plagiarisms of works by C.F.J.
Dowsett from London's School of Oriental
and African Studies
and Robert Hewsen from
Rowan College.
But plagiarism was just the beginning.
Russian ethnologist Viktor Schnirlman
found that Bunyadov had
systematically altered medieval
texts, literally using "find and replace"
to change Armenian to Albanian throughout
historical documents.
This wasn't French pseudo-history.
This was state-sanctioned academic fraud,
taught in schools for 60 years.
Azerbaijan's Institute of Oriental
Studies is still named
after Bunyadov today, despite
documented plagiarism that
would end any academic's career.
Why would Azerbaijan embrace
such obvious falsification?
Because in territorial disputes
historical precedence matters.
If Armenians were always there, if those
churches were always
Armenian, then Azerbaijan's
claim weakens.
Creating Caucasian Albanian heritage
provided an indigenous
Christian past that predated
Armenian presence.
Not all historical
distortion is deliberate fraud.
Sometimes, well-meaning attempts at
naturality create their own distortions.
Thomas de Waal's Black Garden became the
definitive Western
account of the conflict.
Based on over 120 interviews from all
sides, it aimed to rise
above nationalist propaganda.
De Waal's influential conclusion was that
much of the Karabakh conflict was, all in
the mind, constructed on national stories
that were often demonstrably false.
This sounds balanced, but German
researcher Christian Kolter
identified a crucial omission.
De Waal never mentions the 1823 census,
the single most
important demographic document
predating Russian resettlement.
This illustrates a common
problem in conflict reporting.
The false balance fallacy.
When one side has stronger evidence, but
both sides are given
equal weight, the result isn't
neutrality.
It's distortion.
Here's what makes this conflict
especially heartbreaking.
Ordinary Armenians and Azerbaijanis
actually did live as
neighbors and friends.
This isn't mythology.
It's documented fact.
In Shusha, before it was burned to the
ground, there was widespread
intermarriage between
communities.
Zaur, an Azerbaijani policeman, had two
close Armenian friends.
Viggen and Surik, they grew up together,
played volleyball and
soccer, helped each other on
the black market.
When Zaur went to the army, one of them
paid for his haircut
as a good luck gesture.
During the war, Zaur had nightmares about
seeing them through his gunsights.
The Jaffarov family, who lost their son
in 1992, told researchers the same thing.
"We live normally with the Armenians.
They believe the destructive hatred came
from outside, not from
within their community.
Even today, in the Georgian village of
Khojorni, Armenians and
Azerbaijanis still live together
peacefully.
At Armenian weddings,
they sing Azerbaijani songs.
At Azerbaijani weddings,
they sing Armenian songs.
As one villager put it,
"They quarreled over land.
We have no problems over land."
So what destroyed
these genuine friendships?
Government manipulation on both sides.
In July 2002, former Azerbaijan
president, Heydar Aliyev, admitted to
deliberately encouraging
Azerbaijani settlement in Nkorno-Karabakh
during the 1970s to alter demographics.
Meanwhile, despite Azerbaijani's
compromising 23% of Karabakh's
population, Armenians
monopolized all administrative positions.
Armenian schools were forbidden from
teaching Armenian history.
Azerbaijani villages
received less infrastructure.
Both Soviet and post-Soviet governments
turned demographic
competition into policy.
They transformed neighbors into
statistics, friends into threats.
As one researcher observed, "There is no
innate hostility between
Armenians and Azerbaijanis."
In neutral Georgia, all
supposed ethnic hatreds die away.
The real tragedy isn't that people are
lying about past harmony.
It's that the harmony was real and
political elites destroyed it.
Ordinary people paid the price for
demographic games
they never asked to play.
The children who grew up in the 1970s
learning these incompatible
histories became the soldiers
of the 1990s.
The verified numbers are staggering.
The first war from 1988 to 1994 killed
between 25,000 and 30,000 people.
That's roughly the
equivalent to wiping out a small city.
700,000 Azerbaijanis were forced from
their homes in Armenia and
the occupied territories.
Imagine the entire population
of Boston suddenly homeless.
Meanwhile between 350,000 and 500,000
Armenians fled Azerbaijan
according to the Council of
Europe.
Entire communities that had existed for
centuries vanished overnight.
The 2020 war compressed similar
devastation into just 44 days.
Over 7,000 soldiers dead.
Mostly young men born
after the first war ended.
These weren't just numbers.
They were teenagers and young adults
killing each other over
competing versions of history
their professors knew
contained fabrications.
Both sides systematically
destroyed the other's heritage.
Armenian churches destroyed, Azerbaijani
mosques vandalized, each
trying to erase physical
evidence that
contradicted their narrative.
Then September 2023
delivered the final act.
In a single week, UN monitors counted
100,000 Armenians
abandoning everything they owned.
Not because they were
colonizers, as Azerbaijan claimed.
Not because they faced
genocide, as Armenia claimed.
But because fabricated history had made
coexistence impossible.
What happened in Karabakh isn't unique.
It's a template being used worldwide.
The formula is consistent.
First simplify complex
history into binary narratives.
And claim pure indigenous
status while denying the others.
Then find academics to
legitimize your version.
Teach it as fact to children.
And then use it to
justify contemporary policies.
In Myanmar, the claim that Buddhism is
under existential threat
from Muslim invaders justifies
violence against the Rohingya, who lived
there for generations.
It's never about what actually happened.
It's about creating a simple story that
justifies current political goals.
So how do we immunize ourselves against
historical manipulation?
Real history is always messier than
political mythology.
If a complex conflict has a simple
historical explanation,
you're probably hearing propaganda.
Real historical relationships are
complicated, contested and full of
inconvenient facts for
all sides.
And thirdly, not all
historical claims are equally valid.
Some have evidence, some have ideology.
Learn to distinguish.
Because here's what
studying Karabakh teaches us.
When politicians invoke history to
justify current policies,
they're usually not doing
history.
They're doing politics
with a historical costume.
In 2024, Armenia formally recognized
Nagorno-Karabakh as
Azerbaijani territory and began returning
disputed border areas.
In May 2024, Armenia handed over four
strategic villages to Azerbaijan,
abandoned settlements
that had been under
Armenian control since the 1990s.
By August 2025, both leaders were at the
White House, initially a
memorandum of understanding.
They promised to jointly nominate Donald
Trump for a Nobel Peace
Prize, praising his role
in bringing them closer to peace.
But tellingly, they only
initialized the document.
They didn't sign a binding treaty.
Think about this trajectory.
After all the mythology, all the death
and all the
destruction, Realpolitik is slowly
winning.
The fabricated history that justified
three wars and massive
ethnic cleansing didn't
change the final outcome.
It just added zeroes to the body count
while prolonging the suffering.
The next time you see historical claims
used to justify ethnic
conflict, and you will,
remember Karabakh.
Remember how fabricated
history became real graveyards?
You now have tools most people lack.
You can recognize when complexity is
being weaponized into
simplicity, when ancient grievances
are being manufactured, when historical
rites are masking contemporary ambitions.
Because understanding how selective
history destroys
communities isn't just academic
knowledge.
This immunization against the oldest form
of political
manipulation, the mythology changes.
The pattern doesn't.